Ahora vamos a encontrar el valor de esta masa
misteriosa y lo vamos a hacer utilizando matemáticas.
Las matemáticas son solo un lenguaje, el
uso de símbolos para establecer relaciones
entre las cosas y te invito a construir una
forma matemática de expresar esto que estamos
viendo aquí, lo que está pasando en esta balanza.
Y te voy a dar algunas sugerencias, por ejemplo,
podemos pensar que las masas de los objetos
que están en los brazos de la balanza son iguales.
Veamos qué es lo que tenemos del lado izquierdo.
Primero puedo observar que tenemos a nuestra
masa misteriosa que la vamos a denotar con
la interrogación, pero no es lo único que
tenemos, también tenemos 3 kilogramos,
así que voy a escribir, la interrogación para
nuestra masa misteriosa que también está
en kilogramos, más 3 kilogramos,
¿y qué tenemos del lado derecho?
Tenemos, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10...
10 kilogramos.
Sí, lo que tenemos es 10 kilogramos,
¿y qué mas podemos saber?
Pues bien, podemos saber que las masas de
ambos lados son iguales porque la balanza
está en equilibrio, de la manera en que fue
dibujada, esa balanza está en equilibrio.
Entonces sabemos que estas dos cosas son iguales,
¿y qué es lo que hemos hecho?
Pues construimos una ecuación, en la que
tenemos nuestra masa misteriosa,
con la interrogación y que es nuestra incógnita, a la que si le sumamos 3, es igual a 10.
Y teniendo esta ecuación podemos
resolver para la incógnita
y podremos saber esta incógnita que valor tiene.
En el video anterior, aprendimos que si yo
quiero saber el valor de esta masa misteriosa,
tendría que remover estos 3 kilos que están
del lado izquierdo.
Pero también aprendimos que tengo que hacer
algo para que la balanza se conserve en equilibrio.
Eso fue lo que vimos en el video anterior.
Entonces tendremos que remover 3 kilogramos
de ambos lados, quitar 3 de un lado y 3 del
otro para conservar el equilibrio.
Y matemáticamente sería equivalente a restar
3 de ambos lados, porque si yo restara nada
más de un lado, ya no serían iguales, entonces
tenemos que restar 3 de ambos lados,
así que restaremos 3 de cada lado, de manera que
conservemos la balanza en equilibrio.
Del lado izquierdo, ¿qué tendremos?
Pues se quedará solo el símbolo de la interrogación,
entonces del lado izquierdo se queda solo la interrogación,
¿y del lado derecho qué tenemos?
10 menos 3, que es 7, sí, 10 menos 3 es 7
y lo mismo se observa en nuestro dibujo, nuestra
masa misteriosa es igual a 7 kilogramos.
La interrogación es igual a 7 kilogramos,
como aquí se puede observar.